you are given the following starting
numbers and rules for two sequences of
numbers so the first sequence sequence X
starting starting number should be 1 and
then the rule is add one sequence y
starting number should be 5 and then the
rule should be add 5 fill in the table
with the first 3 terms of x and y then
plot the ordered pairs X comma Y on the
graph below so let's see sequence X they
say the starting number the starting
number should be 1 so the starting
number is 1 and then the rule to get to
the next number you just add 1 so 1 plus
1 is 2 2 plus 1 is 3 fairly
straightforward now let's look at
sequence Y they saying the starting
number should be 5 starting number five
and then the rule is to get the next
term we just add 5 so 5 plus 5 is 10 10
plus 5 is 15 now they want us to plot
these things so let's see and we plot
them we plot them as ordered pairs so
we're going to the point 1 comma 5 so
when X is 1 Y is 5 we see that there X
is 1 Y is 5 when X is 2 y is 10 when X
is 2 y is 10 and then when X is 3 y is
15 when X is 3 y is y is 15 and we see
that for every for every one we move to
the right for every one we increase in
the horizontal direction every one we
increase in X we increase 5 4 we
increase 5 for y we increase 1 for X we
increase 5 for Y so now we just have one
less thing to answer the terms in
sequence y our blank x the terms in
sequence x so you immediately see this
term 5 is 5 times 1 10 is 5 times 2 15
is 5 times 3 and it makes sense you
started 5 times higher and here you
added 1 each time and we see that
visually right over here we add
on each time while here we add five
times as much each time we had five each
time so the terms in sequence why are
five times the terms in sequence X we
got it right